Intelligence
Wizard,
you can be bound by something
[Music]
Students, we're going to
lock down the college.
So let's go
find the lost magic book. I wonder
what the culprit wants to do with the magical power he stole.
I'll give it back.  Think about how your child will survive,
and never hesitate.
Descendants of magicians are
bound to their homes from the moment they are born.Before,
you would have
swallowed every complaint just because you were told to do so, but now it's different.  I do
n't know, I don't know,
what do you mean by "fan"? No matter how I try, I
'm complacent in the outside world where I'm tied down. I
know that, but if I put up with it now, she'll die, right? We're
magicians, and it's just
me.